best songs of the past have become
classics almost from the moment we first
heard them on the soundtrack from the
bird first winter the Continental
through over the rainbow when you wish
upon a star white Christmas and so many
others I wish I had written and though
they certainly deserve the awards they
received the so-called losers were
pretty big winners to me like that my
foolish heart yeah magic things in the
night pennies from heaven lonely going
far away I can't take that away from me
I've got you under my skin right all
those and what's new pussycat the look
of love Alfie I know I know you know and
I still can't understand why a great
song like what are you doing the rest of
your life didn't win an Oscar well you
see it lost two raindrops keep falling
on my head right and now for the five
best songs nominated this year all that
love went to waste music by George Barry
lyrics by Sammy Kahn Live and Let Die
music and lyrics by Paul and Linda
McCartney love music by George Bruns
lyrics by Floyd Huddleston the way we
were music by Marvin Hamlisch lyrics by
Allen and Marilyn Bergman nice to be
around music by John Williams lyrics by
Paul Williams may I have the envelope
please
the winners are
more of intense I positively obscene how
many of these you hear it's very lovely
I'd like to thank all of you I'd like to
thank race dark for beautiful picture
and Sydney [ __ ] and Barbra Streisand
the best singer that any lyric writer
could ever have
I can only have my thanks to all of you
and again to Barbra it's just wonderful
thank you very much I feel we can talk
as friends because I think I know you
so gain listen to me you know what
you're terrific I want to thank the
Academy again as it were and there are
three as they are and I want to
particularly thank some wonderful people
who took the chance a long time ago when
I got into this business and that was
Sam Spiegel who gave me my very first
job and my agent Peter faith and my
manager Alan Carr and a man who really
believed in this song and really helped
us all the way which was Marty argument
as thanks mighty mighty mighty to all of
you to all of them and to all of you
you've done it for this year thank you